[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat les femmes
représentent près de la moitié des
actifs et pourtant le monde du travail
est loin d'être peints en rose
discriminer sur la fiche de salaire les
femmes touchent en moyenne 25 % de moins
que les hommes et à profit la poste égal
cet écart est de 9%
discriminer également dans leur carrière
malgré un niveau d'études supérieur à
celui des hommes
les accès de moins facilement postes de
cadres et que dire de leur présence très
discrète au sein des comités exécutifs
et à la présidence d'entreprises où
elles représentent respectivement 15 et
3 % des effectifs
pourquoi ce plafond de verre est-il
particulièrement marquée dans les
yvelines
comment lutter contre ce phénomène pour
en débattre j'accueille à cette table
gérard martinez secrétaire national du
syndicat cfe cgc vous êtes en charge des
questions économiques mais également des
inégalités salariales à côté de vous y
accueille également flavie hourtoule où
vous êtes avocate spécialisée en droit
du travail mais également une ancienne
rh et enfin gabriel schütze musette
sociologue à l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines spécialisés
notamment sur les questions de genre et
du droit du travail
alors il faut savoir que les fiches de
paye c'est quand même le dernier tabou
un peut-être l'un des plus grands à bout
au sein de l'entreprise
cette opacité favorise une sorte de
discrimination qui aujourd'hui je le
rappelle est généralisée aussi bien des
ouvrières que des professions
intermédiaires que des cadres mais
est-ce que selon vous c'est quelque
chose dont les personnes ont vraiment
conscience à l'intérieur des entreprises
qui vont commencer par cette question là
alors moi je suis à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise moi même et puis on a
beaucoup de collègues représentants
syndicaux qui se sont effectivement il
ya une conscience très claire de
cette inégalité salariale alors après
c'est pas un sujet qui est facile à
aborder notamment à défendre vis-à-vis
de la hiérarchie ou des directions
d'entreprises
ceci dit les gens perçoivent bien
l'inégalité comme vous l'a rappelé les
9%
celle là elle est très visible et puis
il ya des causes multiples qui explique
les 17% qui conduisent de 9 à 26
finalement et qui sont en particulier le
plafond de verre mais pas uniquement le
recours au temps partiel qui est
beaucoup plus important pour les femmes
qu'il soit choisi ou imposé d'ailleurs
et puis d'autres facteurs comme le fait
d'avoir des congés de maternité qui
freine quand même les évolutions cet
emprunt pour pour les employeurs
notamment vous vous êtes une femme vous
allez tomber ensemble
forcément il n'y a pas d'augmentation ni
rien à ce que c'est aujourd'hui oui dans
des complexes de politique salariale
contrainte ça existe d'accord peut-être
que ces anciennes rh on le rappelle est
ce que c'est quelque chose de l'autre
côté on va dire de la barrière qui est
vraiment je pense que la bombe ont parlé
un petit peu de ça tout à l'heure la
prise de conscience collective elle
existe personne va vous dire que les
femmes sont si bien payées que les
hommes je pense que maintenant ça c'est
acquis après individuellement c'était
plus compliqué quand on est dedans de se
rendre compte qu'on est discriminée à
cause de ça et de voir jusqu'où ça peut
aller en termes de conséquences moi je
vois des conséquences individuelles qui
peuvent être assez lourde j'ai des gens
qui dépendent des femmes qui peuvent
faire d'un burnout à cause de ça petit à
petit elle s'enferme dans ce cycle un
petit peu négatif donc je pense que
globalement tout le monde est d'accord
sur le sujet après individuellement
c'était des fois un petit peu plus
difficile et puis c'est juste difficile
de s'admettre qu'on est moins bien payé
qu'un homme femme car c'est quand même
une prise de conscience qui est pas tout
le temps évident cinq ans à dire qu'il
ya quand même une sorte de ça existe
mais peut-être pas moi je n'ai pas envie
de regarder la chose pour moi en tout
cas des expériences que j'ai pu voir oui
un petit peu de seins d'accord enfin moi
je
j'étais un peu surpris nous entendre
dire que la prise de conscience était si
forte que cela dans les entreprises et
que tout le monde avait bien conscience
qu'il y avait des inégalités salariales
enfin souvent on croit que c'est dans
l'entreprise d'à côté mais que chez nous
dans l'entreprise dans notre entreprise
dans notre association dans notre
ministère
il n'ya pas d'inégalité salariale parce
que justement ces deux égalités elles
sont relativement subtil c'est
enfin c'est extrêmement rare on dispute
aussi tout à l'heure que l'on dise tu es
une femme donc je ne vais pas t'embauche
et où je ne vais pas te rémunéré plus ça
passe souvent par des canaux beaucoup
plus subtil c'est à dire ce que vous
pouvez développer
oui alors c'est ce qu'on appelle le
plafond de verre enfin le fait de
retrouver de moins en moins de femmes a
fait au fur et à mesure qu'on s'élève à
un niveau hiérarchique ça concerne tous
les secteurs
ça concerne la magistrature ça concerne
les entreprises à conserver adversité
enfin on retrouve le plafond de verre
absolument partout plus on s'élève dans
la hiérarchie moins on a deux femmes et
les femmes qui arrive à des niveaux
élevés de responsabilité sont moins
payés que leurs homologues accompli mais
comment est ce qu'on arrive à expliquer
ça autant le constat est très claire on
regarde notamment au niveau du cac 40 ce
cas il me semble deux femmes qui sont à
la tête d'entreprises
comment ce qu'on peut l'expliquer
pourquoi maintenant pourquoi moi je
pense qu'il ya une évolution alors qui
vient de en particulier dans les
entreprises de la financiarisation qui
fait qu'il ya des management qui sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus directif voire
dur et finalement les femmes ne se
reconnaissent - ils sont moins il ya un
côté humain chez les femmes qui est
beaucoup plus développée et les hommes
arrivent les des hommes arrivent plus
parce que quand il faut des management
directif et ses promesses d'abord des
hommes parce que les femmes sont plus
sensibles généralisée chacun chaque
personne chaque individu a son style
savez ce que vous dites les traits
généraux les traits généraux sont quand
même assez cela moi j'ai le sentiment
aussi que les femmes réclament moi c'est
bon on approche aussi tendance à moins
demandés ont tendance à dire je fais
bien mon travail à un moment je vais
avoir la reconnaissance qui va qui va
arriver parce que je travaille bien et
c'est un moment ça va bien se passer est
souvent là où il ya quand même une
petite désillusion et le pourquoi il ya
des écarts je pense qu'à un moment pour
moi en tout cas là aussi un
les décideurs sont plutôt souvent des
hommes je pense qu'à un moment il ya des
propositions qui sont faites il ya des
décisions qui sont prises dans les
enveloppes budgétaires et qu'à un moment
il ya une espèce de cooptation ou
coproduits je sais pas ce copinage qui
prime et encore plus avec un chez soi
c'est soit conscient j'ai l'impression
c'est plus des phénomènes un petit peu
un petit peu inconscient ça se pratique
comme ça on s'en rend même pas compte
alors oui moi je voudrais intervenir la
cieux puisque le enfin il ya beaucoup
d'études qui montrent que le style de
management en fait il ne dépend pas
tellement du sexe de la personne mais
beaucoup de la taille des équipes à
gérer du secteur dans lequel on est mais
aussi de la culture d'entreprise
il ya des îles des entreprises qui est
requiert tel ou tel type de management
donc je suis pas du tout certaine
accueilli un management qui soit plus ou
moins masculin plus ou moins féminin en
revanche par contre ce qui est certain
c'est que il ya des obstacles dont vous
avez évoqué la question de la cooptation
donc c'est certain là aussi que quand on
doit promouvoir quelqu'un on a tendance
à promouvoir quelqu'un qui nous
ressemble donc plutôt des hommes plus
tôt des blancs plutôt quelqu'un qui sont
passe aussi par les mêmes cursus de
formation il ya des entreprises on va
favoriser par exemple les
polytechniciens et les politiciens
seulement ceux qui n'ont pas fait
polytechnique bombay se retrouve à haute
de c2c promotion du hockey à la question
de la cooptation mais il ya aussi
d'autres d'autres phénomènes dans les
entreprises françaises on valorise
énormément il ya une vraie prime à la
présence on est sur une culture du
présentisme il ya une culture de la
réunionite aiguë qui vous prend à 18h30
tout d'un coup il faut qu'il m'en faire
une réunion donc ce type de relation au
temps de présence c'est quelque chose
aussi qui va se transformer en handicap
pour les femmes au moment d'accéder à
des responsabilités dans la mesure où la
répartition entre hommes et femmes dans
les couples des charges du traitement de
la charge de travail domestique et du
travail parental donc s'occuper de faire
les courses de faire le ménage de faire
faire les devoirs aux enfants d'aller
les amener leurs activités etc
on sait que c'est une recharge qui
repose pour ces deux tiers quand même
sur les femmes dit autrement les femmes
en font deux fois plus
là vous avez parlé de sujets notamment
la culture d'entreprise même si le
présent sionisme est ce que ça c'est des
choses qui sont vraiment clairement mis
sur la table aujourd'hui au sein
d'entreprises ont clairement mis sur la
table je pense pas comme ça mais les
femmes ont une image
moindre disponibilité que les hommes
vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre de
d'accord naturelles sont prêtes à
sacrifier la jeune femme il a plutôt que
les hommes qui en priorité leur carrière
plutôt que voilà je pense qu'il ya ça
mais encore une fois si on analyse la
cause
il ya des remèdes pour traiter ça en
particulier on parlait des yvelines où
le monde du travail est très tertiarisée
finalement il ya beaucoup de travail de
bureau etc
le télétravail est une des réponses à ce
problème de disponibilité que je
m'assurer qu'on parle de travail qu'on
est sain popularisé pourtant ça ne
fonctionne pas le sentiment que ça
évolue sur le télétravail la
réglementation est un petit peu plus
souple est que les dernières réformes et
j'ai de plus en plus de demandes sur du
des chartes sur télétravail charte sur
droit à la déconnexion
donc je sens qu'il ya quand même une
appétence un intérêt un petit peu plus
important sur ces sujets mais ça que le
télétravail a fait peur pendant des
années parce que en tant que manager on
a l'impression si on n'a pas la personne
sous les yeux elle travaille pas donc
forcément un moment faut sortir de ce
schéma là moi j'ai le sentiment que ça
change et ça effectivement c'est un
facteur qui peut faciliter le travail
des femmes et la prise de responsabilité
il ya d'autres facteurs aussi au niveau
des organisations qui font que les
femmes vont être moins souvent promu que
les hommes au delà de la question du
présentisme il ya aussi en fins très
souvent pour obtenir une promotion pour
grimper dans la hiérarchie pour faire
une belle une belle carrière
il faut être prêt à une certaine
mobilité géographique mobilité
géographique ça veut dire être prêt à
déménager
ça veut dire que le conjoint ou la
conjointe doit trouver un nouvel emploi
ça veut dire que les enfants doivent
changer d'école donc ça renvoie aussi à
des négociations conjugale et là aussi
on sait que dans les couples eh bien ces
négociations conjugale elles seront
elles se font beaucoup plus souvent au
détriment des carrières féminines sous
langues dont l'anglais j la carrière de
l'homme encore fait pour vous résumer en
fait les inégalités salariales sont le
reflet des inégalités au sein du couple
un non pas selon elles sont le résultat
d'une d'une politique aussi au sein des
entreprises la prime au présentisme le
fait que pour accéder à certaines
fonctions il faille d'abord avoir tourné
sur un certain nombre de sites qu'il
faille avoir accepté certaine mobilité
donc il ya des solutions qui sont à
l'extérieur de l'entreprise au sein la
répartition des tâches domestiques dans
le couple mais à des solutions qui sont
aussi dans la culture d'entreprise dans
l'organisation du travail très
clairement
l'entreprise a une responsabilité là
dessus des rations
petite réaction sais pas si c'est la
cause ou la conséquence mais c'est avec
l'argent c'est le nerf de la guerre
donc à un moment quand vous êtes un
couple et qu'il ya des décisions à
prendre déclin doit réduire son activité
forcément vous allez privilégier celui
qui gagne plus et c'est un débat qui est
rationnel etc et ça veut dire c'est
normal de prendre ce choix là à partir
du moment où les femmes gagnent
proportionnellement moins effectivement
le choix se fait souvent au détriment
des hommes et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que ça change aussi crème
j'ai quand même le sentiment que les
hommes prennent de plus en plus leur
place là dessus je suis plutôt plutôt
positive moi je pense que quand même il
ya une une des causes de ce problème
d'inégalité c'est aussi la
désorganisation un peu du travail c'est
à dire on fait beaucoup plus de choses
maintenant dans l'urgence qu'on ne
faisait avant et il faut être très
réactif donc effectivement le td un des
obstacles au télétravail c'est à dire
mais moi je vais avoir les gens sous la
main parce que si j'ai un truc urgent et
c'est alors qu'il peut y avoir des
vraies urgences mais en fait elles ne
sont pas si fréquentes que ça et on a
tendance aujourd'hui et c'est les modes
de travail qui ont poussé vers ça le
fait de par exemple dans une entreprise
industrielle bas il faut pas avoir de
stock
parce que les stocks faut les financer
quand on a pas de stock dès qu'il ya une
rupture d'approvisionnement tout est
dans l'urgence si vous voulez on sait il
faudrait un moment donné et établir des
valeurs comme la qualité de vie au
travail la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises au même niveau que les
exigences économiques pour que les gens
retrouvent finalement intra une qualité
de travail qui permettent d'avoir des
femmes aussi bien que des hommes dans
ces postes y compris à responsabilité
dans cette qualité de travail on
pourrait aussi faire en sorte que les
entreprises acceptent que les hommes
prennent leur congé paternité à l'heure
actuelle le congé paternité qui sont
quand même très peu pris dans leur
intégralité
et enfin sachant que y'a quoi il ya neuf
jours dix jours congé paternité mais je
suis mal
deux semaines être extrêmement qu'on
essaie sait même pas pris donc fin c'est
ça fait référence à cette culture de la
disponibilité effectivement cette notion
d'urgence j'assumerai classe où la main
est-ce qu'on voit lorsque ont pris
l'enfant à trois ans est ce que
justement notamment dans les yvelines
comme on a dit tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment un secteur tertiaire il ya
énormément de cadres et c'est lui
notamment dans ce niveau de cet échelon
cent des entreprises qu'on commence à
négocier son salaire et cela on voit des
écarts très importants au niveau du
salat comment expliquer ça ce que
justement il ya ce syndrome de la bonne
élève qui attend que le
jean team manager lui donne sa note
roues les femmes savent pas négocier oui
je pense que la culture de la
négociation chez les femmes elle n'est
pas si évidente que ça moi je le vois
tous les jours on négocie tous dans tous
les domaines d'activité c'est pas si
évident que ça de demander je demandé
d'obtenir de construire une négociation
ça se construit vous voulez obtenir un
objectif je suis pas sûr qu
effectivement on développe ses
compétences de négociations de manière
aussi forte entre les hommes et les
femmes après là aussi c'est que ma
perception toute personnelle j'ai pas
fait d'études sur le sujet mais ce que
je ressens en tout cas et ça il ya une
difficulté à négocier à assumer quelque
chose allait réclamer à le demander et à
plus un petit peu je pense qu'il ya un
phénomène quand même assez générales et
qui concerne tant les hommes que les
femmes qui est un peu une désaffection
pour les fonctions d'encadrement si vous
voulez il ya des gens qui aujourd'hui en
particulier les jeunes ressentent qui a
plus de servitude et d'inconvénients à
prendre des responsabilités à s'engager
dans l'entreprise
que qu'il ya davantage en particulier en
termes de rémunération parce que l'
équilibre vie privée professeur vive
professionnellement et un peu dégradée
etc et s'y ajoute pour les pour les fans
je pense un sentiment un peu de
culpabilité en disant ah oui je sens je
perçois que j'ai une disponibilité
potentiellement inférieure à celle des
hommes est ce donc j'hésite à aller
négocier une promotion comme le ferait
plus facilement un homme d'accord dans
le sens d'autoprotection pour la vie a
personal voulait jeter quelque chose oui
mais alors moi je trouve ça un petit peu
problématique de de rabat cette
responsabilité sur les femmes dire que
finalement les obstacles sont dans leurs
têtes sont aux censures elle négocie pas
assez se font pas assez confiance certes
tout cela existe probablement enfin je
pense que c'est indéniable mais
j'aimerais aussi faire remarquer que les
femmes qui osent enfin souvent
l'ambition féminine est très suspecte
aussi on les renvoie dans les cordes on
dit mais pour qui est ce qu'elle se
prend qu'est ce que c'est que cette diva
enfin qu'est ce qu'elles demandent et
puis les hommes on leur demande pas de
poser souvent leur propose en fait on en
revient à la question de la cooptation
sait aussi que enfin voilà il faut faire
des preuves supplémentaires quand on est
une femme pour pouvoir se permettre de
demander ce genre de choses donc ce fait
que les femmes n'oserait pas ne
demanderait pas à s'autocensurer quelque
part c'est aussi une anticipation pour
elle une anticipation du probable en
fait hein c'est aussi une
intériorisation de ce qu'elle risque de
pain ce qu'elles ont des chances
d'obtenir était alors vous avez parlé
notamment d'une culture d'entreprise ce
et masculine qu'est ce que serait une
autre culture d'entreprise pour pas dire
féminine ou alors mixte justement qui
n'a qu'à quoi ça ressemblerait alors que
se rassembleraient je ne suis pas
cassandrin mais effectivement ça
ressemblerait à plus de transparence sur
les règles de promotion mais aussi sur
l' embauche ça ressemblerait à une
entreprise qui penseraient pas justement
de façon essentialiste que les femmes
ont certaines qualités
les hommes en ont d'autres et donc il
faudrait mettre tel enfin selon leur
sexe faudrait placer les gens à tel ou
tel type de poste et tel ou tel type de
responsabilité ça ressemblerait à
effectivement quelque chose de plus
souple où il y aurait peut-être plus de
télétravail où il y aurait plus de congé
paternité où on ferait pas des réunions
à 18 heures voilà je reprends un petit
peu ce que j'ai dit jusqu'à présent mais
enfin je t'ai modèle d'entreprise sont
en train de se développer là dessus dit
féminin et masculin mais effectivement
de plus en plus céder des sujets qui
émergent des petites structures et qui
qui sont intéressants mais du coup il
permette l'égalité réelle
moi je voulais juste indiqué que en tant
qu'organisations syndicales de salariés
en particulier de salariés de la
d'encadrement nous on a développé depuis
maintenant une dizaine d'années un
réseau spécifique pour informer et
former nos militants les nos adhérents à
l'égalité professionnelle finalement
c'est le réseau équilibre chez nous et
on pense que c'est important pour le
bien de l'entreprise pour une entreprise
plus humaine qu'elle soit entre
guillemets plus respectueuse des fins
mais avec une meilleure répartition
qu'est-ce que vous enseignez justement
comment ce qu'on peut enseigner
justement attentes et bien justement à
aider nos collègues femmes à se
désinhiber à pouvoir à dire voilà vous
devez pouvoir
accéder à ce type de fonction comment
vous y prendre et puis comme on est un
syndicat d'encadrement aussi expliquer à
tous nos collègues qui sont en position
d'encadrement qu'il faut qu'ils soient
respectueux de cette égalité et essayer
de promouvoir à chaque fois que c'est
possible dans avec les compétences
nécessaires de promouvoir des femmes
aussi bien que des sommes d'accord
cependant depuis 1972 et me sens quand
l'égalité réelle est inscrite dans la
loi cependant aujourd'hui nous sommes
encore loin
comment expliquer justement ce décalage
entre ce qui a été goûté
aujourd'hui le constat d'échec
visiblement un constat d'échec c'est que
ça va parce que je pense que ça se
décrète pas il ya beaucoup de la norme
donne des orientations après pour que
les choses soient appliquées faut que
les gens veillent à réclamer leurs
droits et veille à ce que les choses se
compliquaient je suis assez d'accord
mais c'est interdit depuis des années
s'est dit ça devrait ne plus être le cas
mais ça continue alors les écarts baisse
qui est plutôt positif mais on décrète
pas tout par une réglementation surtout
si on n'utilise pas et si on ne la fait
pas appliquer est-ce que vous en tant
qu'avocate vous voyez notamment vous
avez des clientes qui viennent vous voir
vous dise j'ai conscience d'avoir été
discriminée je souhaite comme ça
extrêmement rare si je vois qu'il ya
bien qui est qui qui en est à voilà
kim acquis en mal être au travail après
on va chercher des causes on avoir un
petit peu jusqu'où jusqu'où on peut
remonter sûr qu'on peut s'appuyer et à
l'interdiction des discriminations
interdiction des agissements sexistes
aussi je trouve assez intéressant je
pense qu'on en est qu'au début là dessus
c'est quand même quelque chose de qui
peut qui peut aider qui peut être
utilisé mais non j'ai jamais jamais une
femme qui arrive en me disant ça va mal
je suis discriminés parce que je suis
une femme c'est plus un état général et
après on peut éventuellement remonter à
cette cause là dans dix ou si vous
voulez je pense qu'il ya des problèmes
de d'informations aussi sur les
carrières et sur les formations
typiquement aujourd'hui dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs et on sait que ça s'adonne
non-lieu matière à des emplois bien
rémunérés dans l'industrie et pas que
dans l'industrie
on n'a que 30 % de femmes dans les
écoles d'ingénieurs si vous voulez donc
je pense alors il y en a beaucoup plus
en médecine par exemple je pense qu'il
faut aussi informer que maintenant
l'industrie s'est depuis l'époque de
zola et que les femmes peuvent très bien
s'insérer et essayer de s'engager vers
des études d'ingénieur un problème
d'information
oui enfin pour pour rebondir sur cette
idée que l'on peut pas tout régler on
qu'on peut pas décréter l'égalité la
plupart de ces dispositifs et même le
dernier qui était annoncé en fait il
vise c'est
9 à 10%
d'inégalités à travail égal quand le
dispositif qui avait été annoncé
notamment le gouvernement a décidé de
donner trois ans pour aux entreprises
pour pouvoir réserver notamment cet
écart dans un poste équivalent au même
profil même diplôme même diplôme pour
justement annulé sciatique à rentrer au
sinon ils vont établir des sanctions
beaucoup plus élevés jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à présent c'était qu'ils allaient
me reprendre tout à l'heure j'étais
présent se paya % de la masse salariale
la pénalité et maintenant ils disaient
qu'ils allaient augmenter cette pénalité
donc vous ceci est ce que pour vous ça
va être efficace maintenant moi je
trouve que c'est très bien deux c'est
encore une fois c'est très bien de
s'attaquer aux inégalités à salaire égal
mais moi j'espère à travail égal
mais ce que j'aimerais vraiment dire
c'est que c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt quoi c'est à dire que ça par
exemple ça ne va pas s'attaquer au fait
que 80% des emplois à temps partiel sont
occupés par des femmes
ça ne va pas s'attaquer au fait que le
temps partiel est devenue une politique
de gestion de la flexibilité dans un
certain nombre de secteurs comme les
supermarchés comme le nettoyage par
exemple ça va pas s'attaquer au fait
même qu'on a promu le temps partiel
comme une mesure permettant de résorber
le chômage de résorber la crise enfin
voilà là on reste sur ok attaquons nous
à travail égal salaire égal sur la rive
ça sera déjà extraordinaire mais encore
une fois c'est vraiment l'art shakil
arbres qui cachent la forêt puis en
réalité ce qu'on va y arriver
c'est très difficile de démontrer le
travail égal c'est un petit peu une vie
de l'esprit le raisonnement toutes
choses égales par ailleurs c'est un
dessin raisonnement d'économistes dans
la réalité
je me demande dans quelle mesure on ne
pourra pas toujours prouver que bah non
il ya une petite différence ça peut être
cette petite différence qui justifier
les inégalités
enfin je crois que ça va être compliqué
à mettre en oeuvre même si je ne suis
pas juriste n'aurait aucune chance juste
faire expliquer mon petit sourire sur le
pourcentage pas tellement une question
pourcentage c'est plutôt que les
sanctions sont rarement appliquées en a
été
on annonce une sanction une pénalité qui
est forte 1% de la masse salariale
honnêtement ça a dû ça a du poids si
derrière il n'y a pas de contrôle n'y a
pas de sanction ou alors en annonce
comme ce qui est le cas comme sur des
dernières réformes qu'on sera tolérant
au départ du coup ça perd un petit peu
de son important associé à lancer le
quadruplement va être amplement des
contrôles voulait il ya des effets
paradoxaux c'est-à-dire dans il ya des
accords
de politique salariale qui sont négociés
dans les entreprises et on voit souvent
comme close un petit pourcentage qui est
allouée à la réduction des inégalités
salariales entre les femmes et les
hommes si vous voulez mais le
pourcentage est tellement faible que
certains ont fait le calcul qu'il faut
20 ans avec ce pourcentage pour
rattraper les inégalités donc
effectivement je crois qu'il faut quand
même mettre un coup d'accélérateur pour
aboutir quand même à ce qu'il y ait une
vraie égalité je pense qu'on se nos
entreprises ne s'en porteront que mieux
parce que ça génère chez certaines
collègues femmes quand même une
frustration de se dire je suis un peu
entre guillemets discriminer quoi dans
sa pesée passe à autre chose je sur le
fait de décréter par d'énormes l'égalité
ça produisent difficilement des effets
il ya quand même quelque chose qui a été
positif que je jugeais un peu manière un
peu sceptique c'est l'égalité la mixité
pardon sur les listes de candidats pour
les élections après d'aumale pour les
mandats c'est les élections
professionnelles alors pourquoi je vous
souhaite c'est que j'étais sceptique au
départ en me disant serait que c'est un
côté très mathématique donne un homme
une femme un homme une femme ça posait
plein de problèmes en pratique je
m'aperçois quand même du coup qui va y
avoir la force en cette égalité la
meilleure des femmes qui prennent les
mandats syndicaux
on n'a forcé peut-être un petit peu au
départ nos finales chez certaines femmes
qui sont lancés qui l'aurait peut-être
pas fait et de l'intérieur ça va
certainement changer les regarde je les
vois sur les conseillers prud'hommes il
ya beaucoup plus de femmes qu'auparavant
je pense que ça va peut-être changer les
choses de l'intérieur pourtant ça a déjà
été fait en politique notamment on a
bien vu aux cantonales qui avait
aujourd'hui autant de femmes que
d'hommes et pourtant tous les postes on
va dire à pouvoir était toujours honoré
- des hommes donc après c'est plus
facile ce n'est plus pour avoir des
femmes en postant plus d'accord
est-ce que
il est aussi prenez d'autres mesures
notamment pour pouvoir permettre la
réduction des inégalités entre les
personnes qui chantent à temps partiel
et à temps plein rappelant notamment que
30% des femmes travaillent à temps
partiel contre vie pour cent des hommes
c'est à dire que cette précarisation
voulu ou pas et touche essentiellement
les hommes le gouvernement a annoncé
notamment à mettre en place les mêmes
droits ou à la formation est ce que pour
vous ça va permettre de résorber ce
problème là notamment des femmes
discriminées au point temps partiel qui
reste bloqué un même niveau et qui
n'arrivent pas évolué au sein de la
carrière je dois dire que je suis assez
sceptique la sueur sur cette question
parce que enfin je veux dire le tout son
temps partiel soit sur un salaire
partiel c'est aussi un droit à la
retraite partielle dont fins et c'est
vraiment très bien que ça où les mêmes
droits à la formation mais je pense pas
que ça résoudra le problème des
inégalités salariales qui en découlent
des inégalités de carrière ni le fait
qu' on a est normalement de temps
partiel qui sont subis et qui ne sont
pas choisis donc la nation jean pascal
est volontariste
oui tout à fait bien sûr on a des
chiffres là dessus souvent présente le
temps partiel comme étant une mesure qui
permet pour les femmes de concilier leur
vie de famille avec le travail
en réalité on a seulement un temps
partiel sur trois qui est le fruit d'un
choix des femmes pour concilier leur
travail avec leur vie familiale
donc ça pose et le temps partiel est
aussi plus développée chez les moins de
25 ans et les plus de 50 ans donc pas
les âges en fait où les femmes sont en
train d'élever leurs enfants
donc ce discours de la conciliation il
est quand même
il est vraiment très spéciaux et donc
voilà je pense que pour pour lutter
contre les inégalités liées au temps
partiel
il faudrait vraiment lutter contre
l'utilisation de cette mesure comme une
politique de flexibiliser dans certains
secteurs
d'accord aussi le cas de famars décadent
essentiellement moi j'ai rencontré vous
d'avoir les mêmes mais qui effectivement
sont à temps partiel ne travaille pas un
jour par semaine et la même charge de
travail donc elles ont un salaire à
temps partiel mais effectivement présent
un travail à temps plein là pour le coup
c'est même encore plus encore plus
violent parce que vous faites la même
chose durant 4 jours vous êtes payés sur
quatre jours c'est ça devient
extrêmement difficile à suivre pour
beaucoup de femmes oui
temps partiel du mercredi bien bien
connu dans les entreprises
effectivement et je pense
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas assez le
souci de la part des dirigeants
d'entreprise ou des directions
d'établissement de consigner vraiment et
d'avoir une charge de travail adapté à
la réduction du temps de travail
et pourtant c'est nécessaire
effectivement le nombre de femmes qui
sont à 80% qui travaille quand même de
chez elle le mercredi mais elles sont
quand même chez elle pour pouvoir gérer
les enfants et le mercredi scolaire le
dernier mot de cette émission merci à
vous tous d'avoir accepté d'y participer
quand à vous je vous invite à voir et
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet
passer une agréable soirée il ya la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]